darf ich mal einen angreifen einfach
nein macht dass wir wenn wir vom
helikopter bleibt einfach stehen
durch meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen zurück und wollte minecraft
war zusammen mit kinos in der hölle
ich hab mich fackel gemacht so jedoch
doch passt dass immer das wohl wieder
eine hölle wird huber ich hab's 27
netter quartz gefunden ganz krasser
scheiße du bist auch da drin
ich habe zwei zaubert ist sache kann
meerwassers schleim hallo leute mal
ausgeht aber die zuschauer wieder das
war krass das war wie befreit und
natürliche habitat gebiet ihren die
bietrechte kriege gegen diese teile
kaempfert erinnert mich stark an
wir werden wir werden jetzt übrigens das
wird die letzte folge die wir jetzt in
dieser session produziere normalerweise
haben immer drei aufgenommen einfach
weil es angeboten hat man dafür 3 1
voraus aufnehmen aber weil einfach
nichts passiert wir haben schon mal
ernster für die kunden geschrieben leute
am 2 krasser freiheit
ihr dürft uns strömen und auslachen und
ich wäre total film deswegen aber
vielleicht ist er einfach gerade die man
da auch mal ich hab eisenstäbe gefunden
diesen schuss sicher einzelne mal mit
aber weil weil ich mich toll wenn ich
irgendwas findet und ich will und was
passt auch dass ich irgendwas grummeln
das ist bestimmt irgendwie so ein
geheimer ob das erste mal in minecraft
auftaucht in dieser ist bestimmt
allgemeinen magen der knoten es sind
wirklich anfängt runterkomme hier geht's
runter aber was ich glaube nicht ich
glaube nicht dass da irgendwas diese
dinge die kanzlei am abbauen weil die
geben krasse erfahrung also ja fast
alles gegeben nie gemüse ich habe schon
18 level und ich weiß gar nicht wohin
damit ich hab 29
du kannst das problem ist man kann ja
echt gehofft jetzt mal langsam hier ne
verlassen das doch mal die bücherregale
machen ja manchmal kannst du auch mal
gold apfel machen den ich hab mal ich
hab das ist doch ich habe doch ein
crafting table ja aber das hier guck mal
hier ich hab dir ich hab dir goldbeck
gemacht danke mir dankbar und es ist
immer noch sinnvoll mit büchern
verzaubern wird mal was ich was wir
liegen haben ein goldener apfel der
sogar klingelt ist es meiner kanzlei
haben ich habe voll die rüstung und er
okay dann nämlich die goldene messen
hast du hast jetzt genug damit das ist
ein richtiger opel aller damit bis zum
mega direkt ich weiß das ist einer mit
gold äpfel
das ist direkter designer mit gold
machen können wir können uns einmal
langsam hier ich habe hier das ist das
ganze ja und dass das ganze zucker macht
aber irgendwie aus dass die bücherregale
kriegen aber bücherregale so nicht so
sinnvoll sein wie wie dingsbums lobbyist
egal ich habe 29 leben und ich will
jetzt ausgeben kinos ja aber das geht
mit bio regal mit büchern besser
angepasst amerikas mit bücher besser
macht
ich probiere malbüchern okay nein
übrigens auch ein bücher gefunden als
bei den updates bei einer kamera drauf
ist das ist das drauf dreimal effizienz
1 wow das ist ja der absolute bringer
die bücher dann kann ich das mal mit
spitze agieren wo hast du mir erstmal
auch jeder gegeben so soll ich jetzt
soll ich auch nicht gerade im so war
dann mal war spitz hat mit effizienz bei
den damen herren super ich nochmal hier
bücher
so seien solche bücher machen bücher ist
besser glaube ich also mir wurde gesagt
wir sind besser gemacht als bücher und
wenn sie das funktioniert weil wir
einfach in ordnung so war ich muss aber
erstmal hier soviel wieder rausschmeißen
nämlich das alles hier bücher habe ich
jetzt nur noch schön gebunden der stufen
werden wir jeweils wir haben einfach so
jetzt kann ich die bücher verzaubern
es gab einen fahrschein gesammelt weil
wir haben 3 was mache ich denn ich habe
keine ahnung was nicht mache sind so
dumm amizmiz ich habe schutz 1 bekommt
das heißt ich kann
warum ihr das dann kann ich das auf
meine ich habe auf meinem helm schützt
sich einzeln auf meinen stiefeln
schusssicher 1 ja aber ich habe noch das
solltest du solltest nicht schusssicher
du kannst soll das weil ich kann mich
dann schutz zwei machen auf meine die
ares und verstehst was ich meine ja viel
los das okay ich hätte am liebsten gegen
die schärfe
ja das kann ich mal gucken aber dass ob
ich das gleich raus gehen oder so ich
gute ob das funktioniert wie ich dachte
schütz 2 gigawatt los interoute kugel
gestorben wie erst gestern hatte setzte
das cool leather hashtag patricio ich
habe ihn umgebracht
sowas will ich jetzt hier ich wollte dir
weiter weiter verzaubern und das ist
einmal schärfe einstiger hier bitteschön
bitteschön
da ist die schärfe coopers damit
anstellen kann ich okay das war
wunderschön da müsste aber noch muss
nochmal die schwerter erst auf schärfe 1
verzaubern und dann hast du noch nie
schwer da ne du dich so gut weil dann
hättest du das jetzt auch schärfe 200 du
damit um die schärfe 3 bekommen können
oder sie haben ein bisschen unpraktisch
gemacht bei unserer ganzen diaz sind in
afghanistan
ja die sind da auf extreme schärfe
einstigen geben aber das schaffe
einstigen das buch bnd zu gier war der
wahl was du siehst du siehst ich bin ich
ja ich habe einen plan wie bleibe zwei
buch bitteschön ersten schafe zwei buch
macht zusammen das geschäft radierer
schwert das ist wundervoll ja ich habe
ja gesagt ich mache das macht das
effizienter als die polizei erlaubt und
bekommen auch die ganz ohne effizienz
bücher aber meine damen schärfe drei die
erschwert was die ich werde kämpfen den
zins bücher schweiß ich weg ganz ehrlich
die packe ich irgendwo rein und hier
drüben die truhe dann kann er sich
irgendwann freuen denn noch nichts
erreicht hat im projekt immer wenn ware
newswires die boj sucht immer noch
seinen zweiten diamanten mal so witzig
fixies kommen ich finds richtig süß ich
finde irgendwie ich mag den ich mag den
hörer die bei auch also wie gesagt dass
man super schönes gefühl in dem seine
falle reinzuhören irgendwie dann kannst
du mir die kinderkiste was glaube ich
noch mehr zucker gibt mir das nochmal
bitte
weil dann kann ich mich noch vielleicht
noch ein bisschen mehr machen probieren
ein bisschen rum ja darum bundes lecker
boney m wir brauchen eine kiste kinos
ist bist du ein pirat ist dass die kiste
steht da drüben da stehen von glp und so
stimmen wir sind so blöd da ist einfach
so eine kiste wein kaum noch leder total
super
da steht ein kinospot ergänzen nun
einmal rhein gekippt
ja diese scheiss kiste da also wieder
nur effizienz nur schrott stärke du
kannst dir starke doch auf seinen bogen
machen hätte ich ja dann lassen da hab
ich doch ich habe dir mega wie viel
stärker auf dem bogen drauf 22 ich hab
war auch zwei ich kann mein glaube ich
auch drei machen ich guck mal das ist
unsere neue etliche finde ich
wunderschön hier noch dreimal ich
probleme naja ok das ist so wundervoll
unser anders geht übrigens an einem
kaputten ich jetzt meine kiste wieder
weggeschmissen einer zeit ja du ich hab
zwei noch aus der linke zu starke 3
bogen denn nimmst du bist mit bogen
besser glaube ich oder du bist mit bogen
besser kommen hast du das ich habe alles
offen auf seinen bogen braucht anders
und dann ist das glaube ich ganz cool
und stärke 3 bogen stärke 3 die
erschwert wir haben vertraglich 32
kräftig angst davor dass ich diesen
goldenen apfel nicht rechtzeitig essen
werde und nicht mit irgendeinem anderen
scheiß beschäftigen wenn es eine
kampfsituation kommen falls das so sein
wird seit ich böse selbst die wichtigste
aussage die wolle brauche eigentlich
auch nicht sehr stark was hast du
eigentlich sonst weil dann können wir
uns vielleicht ihren tee machen da
drüben hatte ich zwei sand aber nicht
mehr was machst du eigentlich ich gucke
mir unsere ausstand oh das stimmt also
ich weiß es nicht
irgendwer warum stehen die ganze zeit
aber schon ja ja so ich hab noch hier
zwei - nicht nur über das jetzt mal ganz
so sieht man feiern
die auch gar keine fragen die uns
geschickt federn flint und stx ja hast
du flint da wahrscheinlich nicht
doch klar egal ob er tritt ich hatte
viel geld weg ich habe mir so ich habe
so viel flint gesamtmetall jetzt nicht
mal wieder raus aus der hölle dass wir
dann am spongebob können wenn
irgendjemand uns endlich mal irgendeine
anfrage dass das jetzt zurückgehen im
die man alles mit was sie mitnehmen kann
sich dem auch das mit was sie mitnehmen
kann
das war ja mal wieder würde ich also
dieses hellen abenteuer ist was es so
artig und wir waren so knapp vorm tod
krass krass kreiskasse übermütig wurden
das ist wirklich also in der letzte
folge noch zwei jahre warten müssen zu
den koordinaten in der mitte einfach war
die koordinaten waren steht irgendwo
steht nicht mehr da drin oder irgendwas
mit x20 oder so ich guck mal einfach
irgendwie zurücklaufen das werden wir
schon finden denke ich mal oder noch
mehr verlangen
jedes mal wieder zurück dass es nicht
noch mal wieder zurück euro zurückgehen
dabei da lagen jetzt auch wieder hölle
und unser mann ist bauen wir in der
hölle und werden wir anderen ligen
hungertod starb an hunger das gibt es
nicht dass da waren ja wie die ganz
grossen favoriten dafür dass ihr dann
bei allen tolle sachen die komplettesten
spieler sollten ihr zuhause ist auch
gesagt ich glaube ein bisschen links
worauf ich schnell man sich hier
verläuft hier war hier war glaube ich
richtig oder ganz gut aus und dann jetzt
hier links orientierung nord ja aber ich
habe überall fakten gesetzt also von
daher sind wir hier eigentlich richtig
ja sicher okay war warum muss auch
unbedingt mein lover einmal hier auf die
zwei nehmen weil wenn ich wirklich in
der hölle spieler dann glaube ich auf
jeden fall kinos lediglich wirklich
gerne hier dann ja wirklich langsam
ich glaube hier sind auch fackeln und so
das sollte schon soll ich wirklich man
hört auch wieder den gas ganz laut das
ist ja ja es wirklich hier lang
das habe ich erinnere mich an darf ich
mal einen angreifen
einfach nein macht dass wir wenn wir vom
höllental stefanie poppe bleibt bleibt
einfach stehen entspannte ich will noch
abschießen machen vielleicht noch
aggressiver ist ganz ist ganz cool
verschwand die pfeile alles okay sie ich
habe getötet
ich habe ihn einfach getötet kate ja mit
dem stärke 3 bogen ist das ja auch
logisch man sie sind es sind ja wissen
wir auch nicht unterschätzen uns wie
unterschiedlich die nächstens ich weiß
nicht ob wir unseren besten wissen wo
wir hallo da um sich doch noch glücklich
wie goodell uns hier mal hoch hat ich
gerade angst versehentlich wie sind
scheiße gold und apfel ich muss das mal
weg wechsel dass man dass ich den so
auch die vier und dann kann ich denn da
gleich essen noch mal ein bisschen hier
eine erfahrung mitnehmen
ja und wo wohl noch mal irgendwie - - 20
war das hier oben ich glaube es war da
ganz oben oder hier hoch wahrscheinlich
denke ich mal
ja ja ja das war das war ja das war
richtig schwer wie wie auch wie wie
krass ok wir sind aber dass er wirklich
ich glaube das war das erste mal dass
auch so räumt uns nach in der konfi
nicht nicht richtig also dass da jemand
nachts geträumt ist also hoch gelaufen
binder hoch und dort von einem gast
abgeknallt hier oben bin ich hallo hallo
idee ich kenne auch den gas das ist auf
jeden fall wundervoll bildchen abknallen
dann töte ihn ja weißt du die ganze zeit
über euch wahrscheinlich wenig wo bist
du da hier hallo da kommt was geflogen
und wo ist hier das portal noch mal
kräftig ja wurden so ist - ich glaube da
hinten war da eben mal david man
entspannt glaubt auch irgendwo da ich
habe auf jeden fall gutes gewissen was
hier lange ja wir haben einen irgendwann
vor ein paar folgen wenn man mal gesagt
ein
dass ihr uns schreiben können wenn
irgendwelche fragen oder uns habt und da
kam das thema video day auf doch bist du
beim videodreh höchstwahrscheinlich
schon also wieder wieder sicher auf der
gamescom da bin ich ja wirklich jedes
jahr und ich denke wir werden auch
dieses jahr also mit mir wenn ich auch
so ich rede weise dario dortmund mit
anderen netten menschen aber ich denke
ich werde dieses mal auch auf dem video
zu gange sein und auf dem video auf dem
video und mit euch sexuell attraktive
spielchen treiben so ja so gut bei mir
weiß ich noch nicht genau weil ich nicht
weiß wann unsere abifahrt und so ist das
wachstum aber nicht da ist okay ich war
schon ich war schon ein bisschen abseits
vom vom fonds pornos dann gleich
auslaufen
aber du wolltest ob ich noch ein
bisschen was von video erzählt einfach
mal hierhin stellt einfach ein bisschen
mehr reden hier ein bisschen entspannt
frage gerecht werden was schätzen sie
wie lange er noch lebt also ich denke
wir werden in den nächsten wochen
sterben bei boxkämpfen aus sind und
vielleicht mal was real life es gibt für
mich kein release gibt nur noch waren
einmal nix anderes merkmal das ich dass
ich zum einen friedlich einschlafen
werde ist für mich das was ich mir am
angenehmsten vorstellen und auch mit
einem also ich will nicht sterben wenn
ich irgendwie todkrank bin also in einem
angenehmen hohen alter in dem ich aber
noch im vollbesitz seiner geistigen und
im besten fall auch körperlichen kräftig
habe auch ich habe meinen eltern ist
auch schon alles gesagt wenn ich
irgendwann mal also damit die
wahrscheinliche erleben aber ich werde
meinen kindern sagen dass sie mich nicht
links sondern denjenigen altenheim
städten sollen alles mögliche aber ich
will nicht irgendwie mit anderen leuten
die krank sind in einer klinik leben
dann nur damit ich dann noch länger als
eine woche lebe sondern dann halt
irgendwie zwei monate aber dann nur
unter solchen umständen habe ich
wirklich kein bock hab das jetzt mal
kann das ist aber wirklich so da habe
ich einfach keine lust drauf
ja findet finden finde ich schon
verständlich also wenn es natürlich wenn
man eine krankheit oder irgendwas wo
eine gewisse chance auf besserung
besteht dann ergibt das schon sinn aber
sobald du dich so ist dass man das man
einfach nur noch am leben erhalten wird
wäre das für mich persönlich glaube ich
einfach auch nichts also ich möchte
möchte wenden wenn ich lebe dann will
ich leben versteht man glaube ich den
satz wenn ein bisschen
auch denkt gefällt euch hier oder war
besser also ich fange jetzt erstmal an
schillers beide kann man in sehr
schlecht miteinander vergleichen weil
großen projektes ihren schönen thema aus
redest mädchen hast dann plant ihn und
die nächsten voll gemacht und war es
eigentlich immer so to connect auf den
servern denkst dir was macht man da
diese folge auf jeden fall vorsicht
nicht deswegen ich finde war ob man
diesen charakter dass man wirklich mit
ganz anderer spannung dabei ist
mittlerweile hat mittlerweile ist das
nicht mehr so weit ihr hört schon
überall explodiert irgendwas an uns ist
dass relativ scheißegal ich glaube sogar
direkt vor die kripo und lassen das mich
von ihnen wegsprengen sowieso
gelangweilt bin ich aber ich finde hat
beides so seine vorteile
was hast du auch noch kuchen ich warte
die ganze dauert das einfach nur während
unserem gespräch einfach mal jemand
braucht und wann hat es reicht ja nicht
noch einer was ja also ich kann das
insulin und weise unterschreiben zum
einen ist es bei alvaro dass das merkt
man im hintergrund gar nicht das ist ein
extrem aufwendiges projekt weil wir nur
drei folgen produzieren können und ja
immer zusammen aufnehmen wollen sind
conny wirklich und ich die ganze zeit im
durchgehend und kontakt und versuchen
für euch alltäglich die folgen fertig zu
machen und das reicht vom vom auf dem
her ist es ein bisschen an welche herzen
schaden an teilnehmern ein herzhaftes
gemacht bei mir dass ich habe auch
wirklich gut verzaubert hatten viel im
kopf stecken
wunderschön freut mich freut mich ja
also das heißt es ist ein bisschen
aufwendiger in dem fall und man ja
www.wiwi konnte ich schon gerade eben
erwähnt hat das ist eine ganz andere
spannung am anfang jedenfalls gehabt
aber jetzt gerade im zum ende hin und da
muss ich auch eine gewisse art und weise
den anfänglichen kritikpunkten die ihr
für waro genannt hatte schon am anfang
des projekts recht geben es ist wirklich
teilweise so geworden dass einfach
manche teams wie zum beispiel halt nicht
viel nicht viel abbekommen haben von von
anderen teams liegt nicht daran dass in
welche meinten oder das dass wir den
anderen aus dem weg gegangen ja genau
ganz einfach daran dass uns keiner nach
schön und wenn andere drauf sind haben
wir keine zeit aufzunehmen weil es ist
nicht so dass die 24/7 vom rechner
sitzen sondern dann wirklich für
aufnahme termine und kommen so ist das
genau ja also es ist es hat trotzdem
spaß gemacht also tun sollte das ende
meine ich ja gar nicht
aber könnte schon ein bisschen voraus
besprechen und ich find's ganz schön
etwas eigentlich ist es ja die
überlegung ob man das zu einem
jährlichen event macht finde ich super
aber es ist ja auch klar das war jetzt
das erste mal dass wir so ein event
dieser art als als minecraft community
zusammen gemacht haben und dass da
einfach noch an der einen oder anderen
stelle gefeilt werden muss und mal
gucken wie dann vielleicht das mögliche
war o2 wird und du bist raus oder wie
es raus ich gefallen